dann unbürokratische soforthilfe diese
kennen wir bereits aus dem ersten
lockdown aber auch damals gab es viele
fragen wo beantragt ich sie muss ich sie
zurückzahlen wie funktioniert das ganze
überhaupt genau diese fragen möchte ich
jetzt klären mit der anwältin nicole
mutschke mir nun zugeschaltet guten
morgen frau mutschke haben wir gerade
davon gehört bis zu 75 soll man also
zurückerstattet bekommen ist dass ein
kredit oder muss man das wirklich nicht
zurückzahlen
nein das ist tatsächlich eine nicht
rückzahlbare förderung eine
kostenpauschale die man bekommen soll
also das ist kein kredit sondern ähnlich
wie damals überbrückungshilfen oder eben
die korona sofort hilft ist das wirklich
was was die betriebe behalten dürfen
und wer ist alles berechtigt das jetzt
zu beantragen ja also ganz genau wie es
eben auch erhalten wie schon gesagt hat
steht das noch nicht fest ganz klar ist
dass diejenigen betriebe berechtigt sind
die quasi direkt vom ausfall betroffen
sind also sprich die die jetzt nicht
schließen dürfen und da auch in jeder
größenordnung also vom solo
selbstständigen über größere unternehmen
und bei denjenigen die eben indirekt
betroffen sind
da ist auf der seite des ministeriums
noch zu leben dass man da an einer
entsprechenden hilfe arbeitet und wenn
ich berechtigt bin wie einfach ist es
das ganze überhaupt zu beantragen
es soll sehr sehr einfach sein es soll
im prinzip wie bei den
überbrückungshilfen ein online-formular
sein
es soll also wirklich unbürokratisch und
auch sehr schnell gehen so ließ man
jedenfalls zurzeit auf der seite des
ministeriums
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren